Every night during the holy month of Ramadan,...
...Muslims around the world attend an iftar,...
...a meal to break the day's religious fast,...
...but in Iran's holy city of Mashhad, there is an iftar like no other.
During the 30 days of Ramadan, the Imam Reza mosque...
...hosts a break fast of epic proportions.
Every night as the sun sets, thousands of meals are served to hungry observers.
Cooking for that many people can be a daunting job,...
...so they enlist the help of over 400 volunteers.
To pull this off, the volunteer chefs start their day at 5 AM...
...and spend most of their time chopping and stirring the evening's meal.
But 13,000 meals means a lot of food.
The mosque goes through two tons of fresh vegetables, four tons of rice...
...and three tons of meat every single night.
But despite the challenges, volunteers and patrons alike...
...consider it a great honor to attend this special iftar.